having a good time over looking at this
now I'll see you look over to the left
all you see his teeth in the dark this
everybody just smiling is y'all oh oh
that's tough
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with
hacked questions and even hide her wings
and today I'm joined by one of the
busiest actors in Hollywood Michael B
Jordan he's a bonafide leading man you
know him from his award-winning
performances in Creed fufill station and
Friday Night Lights and he can catch him
in one of the year's most buzzed-about
blockbusters black panther in theaters
now Michael welcome to the show man bro
appreciate appreciate it
how are you with hot food I'm okay I
like I like a little spice I like flavor
I like being able to taste you know say
my food but uh yeah we're gonna push
that push that to the max today
[Music]
let's go huh good - what that's good
I want to start by taking it all the way
back I'll give you two curious details I
heard about your childhood and you can
choose which one you want to elaborate
on okay your sister once locked you in a
dryer used to set rolls of toilet paper
on fire
I don't know that must have stopped the
hook on his lungs I've definitely thrown
around the bus like you know for years
about the dryer situation but I was a
pyromaniac growing up I used to live
next door to my grandmother used to
always have incense you know saying good
match nice you just you know spark that
up mark that on fire and just literally
just were lighted on fire or like take
the insect and like poke it through the
shower the plastic shower curtains yeah
I had my fair share of weapons off of
that you ever catch a whuppin for racing
cars fast and furious style as a youth
in New Jersey you did your research huh
yeah my dad shooting me out a bunch of
times used to go down to Avenue P by
cineplex in Jersey City and we said like
definitely like race cars and stuff like
that bassinger Fury has had a big impact
for much other
mm-hmm I'm on a diet right now so this
is like like a cheap meal that I'm happy
to take right now so far so buy me yeah
the warm-ups are good so I read that you
studied Heath Ledger's Joker in
preparation for a black panther and then
when I found most fascinating is that
you lived Erik kill monger for nine
months growing your hair out drinking
and walking around with the chip on your
shoulder and I wonder when you were in
that mode who's the innocent bystander
that caught it you ever snap on a
barista for messing up your praline
lottery yeah no it was a kind of stayed
to myself
Erik didn't really have any family no
real friends and he spend a lot of time
you know in his own head walking around
I didn't feel like myself so I could see
like people kind of like get out of my
way a little bit or like kind of like
they'll see me coming avert eyes you
know it means right that kind of gave me
like the even more confidence that I was
kind of like falling deeper into
character and you called it liberating
what do you miss most about living the
Erik life he just didn't give a [ __ ]
about nothing like he just it was just a
very nonchalant whatever kind of
attitude and then switching gears a
little bit you know the hip-hop
soundtrack it used to be such a big deal
when you think about movies like
Bulworth or above the rim or belly and
then this superhero movie against all
odds seems to be a renaissance thanks in
large part to Kendrick Lamar and I'm
wondering which song brings off hardest
for you on the gym playlist I've been
listening to paramedic a lot paramedics
been going hard and Bryan somehow I
managed to collaborate with Kendrick and
showed him the movie and his voice you
know any kind of like weight stance
right now is the perfect fit for this
movie so yeah paramedic right now I've
been I've been blasting I'm a glassed
pretty hard in a job
[Music]
that's cool
now this is a setup yeah this is the
center I can tell already this is setup
yeah my yeah it's cool to say nothing
yes that's what we want yeah yeah right
now right wall you into a false sense of
security so the Michael B Jordan
blueprint it's all about hard work
whether it's three days in the gym or
living with your parents to stay
grounded
you seem to embody and almost maniacal
like commitment to success but we all
know that there can be a dark side to
greatness so what I want to do is hit
you with some classic rap lyrics about
the price of ambition and I'm just
wondering how they hit your ear that's
not good yeah this first one is from
Drake lately I feel the haters eating
away at my confidence they scream out my
failures and whisper my accomplishments
does that ring true to you no doubt also
doesn't ring true to me but you know
some cold lyrics it's crazy Drake's
Drake's lyrics usually really like you
know ring true first time I really heard
a rapper that's my age whatever spitting
things that I was actually going through
in my life the transition of success you
know I'm saying I'm coming from where I
come from his lyrics usually kind of
like hit me hit me pretty hard let me
try another one for you this is from
childish gambino off I'm alright
being happy is the goal but greatness is
my vision and all these girls are
thinking they compete with my ambition
that's pretty spot-on you know people
don't really understand the sacrifices
you got to make you know like your
ambition comes first and one to be
successful and build that legacy
you usually sacrifice a lot of your own
personal life you know so yeah yeah that
one rings pretty true this next one is
from nas off back when it's pathetic I
don't get the credit I deserve that's
why I hate doing interviews not out
doesn't ring true me not saying I don't
get the credit I deserve but yeah that
one that one that one's just no Blair
[Music]
so this is still safe but still Satan's
little saying I am me down nobody say
suspicious I'm just saying I'll never
see you get nervous really on here so I
gotta check you out just make sure you
know I'm saying well see what I'm
dealing with
all right home school I had to some
house yeah
such a compliment that's always Michael
yeah I appreciate the taken yeah we got
you a bag man I love it I love it so I
know that you commit to every role that
you do and nowhere is that more apparent
than in the lore behind Adonis Johnson
and Creed there's this famous clip
that's been viewed millions of times
online of you taking a brutal right and
falling to the mat is that just another
day on set how bad were you taking a
beating during that yeah man slide just
loves to like you know to dish out
punish me I think he likes to see me in
pain he was a man look I took the real
punches on rocky you gotta take real
punches don't create I say man I got it
slide dated I'm gonna do it I had to
take the real punch and Antonio he gave
me about 40% he said he put about 40% on
that punch it felt like I was in a car
accident for three days man like my neck
my spine the top of my back it was a
yeah it was it was it was a tough hit
but it seemed to gain points with slide
because he said that's called guts
he said they got right back up and did
it again yeah we did it twice was the
first time we didn't even get the shot
like his glove was in the way and
literally blocked it with the connection
or whatever so we had to do it twice and
I'm so crazy cuz I went down and I was
on the mat and I'm just sitting there
and in my head I'm like it felt good it
felt like you know it looked good and
then I popped up and we ended
[Applause]
smoked ghost pepper I heard about them
okay yeah and I want creeps a little bit
mm-hmm yeah it creeps starting to turn
the knob a little just love it's just a
little something okay hit you up yeah
yeah Mike I went from two bites to like
a nibble hi Michael so every Korean
segment on her shell called explain that
Graham we do a deep dive on our guest
Instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context so I'll bust out the
laptop I'll show you the picture and
then you just tell me the bigger story
does that sound good sound Burke all
right
laptop please up first with the guy no
man Jonah hell yeah that's my do man we
were going to see Kanye in New York we
always you know randomly run into each
other at different different events or
whatnot and yeah we pop the photo I was
talking about his beard I was just
because you know it's kind of hard for
me to connect mine you know I'm saying
then we got you know q-tip in the back
randomly I saw him in the back I was I
was not at that step in the back um yeah
became yeah became a cool cool photo
what do you remember about the Met Gala
with Jay
I was almost nervous to get up and go
over to say something because him and
beyond saying had the Met Gala he knows
everybody there whatnot and I was just
like man I got to come over here and
just like you know give him his respect
and just tell him how much you know you
had an impact on me and how much he
motivated me as a home as an
entrepreneur as a business man as a
black man it was a cool moment and he
was just like no he's an around me you
know Santa's take this flick and years
later in New Orleans all-star weekend
that was the first time I had performed
that opened up with the roots that time
and and I was so nervous because I knew
Jay was gonna be there and I didn't know
I was gonna be rapping like that I
thought it's gonna be more spoken word
cuz I'd he told me was like everyone
Doolittle I want you to do a little
spoken word okay cool up do spoken word
that's that's not hard and then we go
for a soundcheck and rehearsals and it's
like I'm on this elevator I'm popping up
by the stage got background dancers it
was like smoke and fire and [ __ ] like
that I was like oh man this is like this
is aggressive at little in-ear joint I'm
like yeah I was not prepared for this
and then when I win
that Don J was like I wasn't sure at
first but after you gotten to your groom
you killed it and I have to get his
stamp of approval that's all I need to
hear no one can say anything yeah I
ain't got to do no more I said it done
crap career finished
beginning in overdone explain that
Graham beginning and over darkness it
you ready to move on Michael let's do it
karma karma comes back kicking your ass
oh okay chief mm-hmm back up the one
mm-hmm mm-hmm
yeah I'll turn the heat up it's awfully
ah yeah yeah that goes mm-hmm
so your commitments at the gym is no
surprise to those who follow you on
Instagram but some might be shocked to
learn that you're actually a very
committed eater is it true that during
the Creed training you took your cheat
days so seriously that you'd wake up
early so you'd have extra hours to feast
yeah without a doubt
oh you're good man you do you're good
you do your research man oh yeah I would
a man that's real mm-hmm I would get up
like an extra hours just so I can get
another breakfast and go down to the
spot call honey sit and eat which is one
of the spots down there in Philly
French toast you know eggs you know
above the work so I would that is real
that is real when you're coming up and
living off of 7-eleven as a youth what
was your go-to way to stretch a dollar
at the convenience store used to give
the frozen pizzas the hot pockets ramen
and I'm saying a couple noodle joints
mm-hmm white cheddar popcorn spicy nacho
Doritos flamin hot cheetos and then get
the nacho cheese from the nacho machine
Alex I had it all that in one bag and
just like air that out I was my go-to I
got doing
[Music]
yeah
so when is it cool to drink you can
go.you has anybody got through the whole
thing without drinking it's happened
like two or three times
alright cool and we'll see if I can get
to my limit keep looking over there like
okay is it true that you form tackle
director Peter Berg during your Friday
Night Lights audition you know how do
you guys get his information man I was
inside the audition room yeah um they
got me trying to remember old [ __ ] and
I'm like what kind of reminisce it's the
holidays I was auditioning for Vince and
he had me improv he was talking me
through how to get my team height you
know saying you the QB you know saying
talk to you guys in the huddle etc etc
and he was playing the defensive player
he was like you know talking [ __ ] across
the line and he was started ad libbing
and going off on a little tangent or
whatever and he got me so fired up that
in my mind I'm like you know what I'm
just gonna tackle this dude I'm just
like just go ahead and just go for it
you know they what they gonna do like
you know I'm not gonna get the role I
guess he was like what were you exactly
had nothing to lose so I just kind went
over and tagging me he really dug in I
think that was to come like one of them
key decisions and me actually getting
the role was the fact that I you know
took it to that level went over attack
with them and then I know that some
directors they're very protective about
all the lines in the script they're very
strict about it but from what I
understand about Friday Night Lights
it's very just let the cameras roll and
then whatever happens happens
and as a young actor what was the bigger
challenge learning to improvise or
learning to play quarterback without
looking like a goofball on TV the whole
football thing I hope at the time in
like I will work out you know couple
hours in the morning right go over to UT
you know saying go down the field you
know get some get some reps in I want
the kind of like look like a real a real
football player when it comes to the
improv stuff I think it was the best
thing for me at that time cuz I just
to live in the moment and listen I still
wanted to keep things about acting you
have to listen very well if you were to
just Chuck a football with everything
that you have right now what are we
talking 30 40 yards or can you just bomb
that thing like Andrew Luck no I could
probably 60 years like I'm confident in
that like one like one more for a little
bit like fresh like we can go right now
I could probably drop your 60 I got a
parking lot and yeah a parking lot with
our needle imma get [ __ ] with somebody
I'll call them yeah we could do it soon
whenever whenever yeah it's the one I
was looking at me since I walked in the
hole behind the sanity things like you
know that's that's aggressive mm-hmm
it's very aggressive yeah yeah yeah man
yeah I don't even taste like flavor
Boris like mm-hmm
it goes face it up get it back in this
town mm-hmm
was that yes whoo so your work spans so
many genres you know from the sorority
girl who just came off a Friday Night
Lights binge to the real Sopranos
diehards I'm sure that you get
approached by so many different kinds of
people do you still get recognized from
the wire - people scream where's Wallace
at you on the street in 2018 drooling
okay you win for I doesn't mean Phillip
that doesn't mean it feels bad okay um I
have nothing to prove whoo yeah I know
right
whoo what was the question again man
do people scream where's Wallace at
Michael B Jordan whoo yeah yeah where's
Wallace yeah I get that a lot um which
it makes me feel all types of ways it's
like all right I'm glad that people
remember this role for over 15 years ago
but did I grow up a little bit do I look
any different like you know Stanley B
Holly where's Wallace like all the time
as a Friday Night Lights fan ever
approached you with some crazy theory
for what they think happened with Vince
Howard football career yeah they got
some that made me became a football
coach did you go to the NFL did you go
to see if like what happened what was
this whole long this whole trajectory
that is real broke because it's like
creeping up and [ __ ] I'll see you let go
to the lab all you see is teeth in the
dark this everybody just smiling is all
messed up and then you know for better
or worse when you star in superhero
movies you end up face to face with
comic-book purists and some of the most
passionate fans and the world is hard to
like look at you and actually you really
try to care about what you said I was
like sometimes I don't know I don't care
what he's talking about right now like
what just a fight for survival so I mean
when you're walking the grounds at
comic-con
what's one fan interaction that you
appreciate is somebody who grew up
around comic books and then one fan
interaction that makes you just want to
run back to the hotel and throw the
curtains I mean they know more comic
book history than I did I
they're on top of the game so I could
always appreciate somebody telling me
something I didn't know so okay cool
that's dilt whenever I never knew that
it makes me run the other way like a
flock of fans you know saying like big
groups that swarm on you a little bit so
you got to kind of like gauge it like is
this dangerous it's can this get out of
hand and then once you make that quick
decision I'm out of it out of there yeah
yeah how many more we got managed to get
these off the tail you look at these
these these guys alright so this one is
Mad Dog 357 with number nine catonian
hmm nah man hiya Pluto neo is that what
it says yeah okay really that is my
Apple Tony oh it means like death
[Music]
uh-huh
[Music]
CEO you know how hot it is he like
trying to hurry up and shoot him you
know so I mmm
there you go me this is a mental
strength at its finest you know I'm
saying it's sneaking your secret
handshake into NBA 2k 17 the most
underrated accomplishment of your career
tall my boys back home in Jersey yeah
for sure that was definitely one I had
to do for them um yeah we uh we got that
we uh we made that happen
mm-hmm oh man you're stuck in your
trailer for six hours between shoots
wasn't one video game one anime series
in one book that you need to hold you
over
wait which one this is the this almond
oh that's the almond that's the
two-percent the old double barrel huh
okay and I'm really trying real hard I
hold on this one mm-hmm
ah you're almost there one punch man
enemy serious one book I can reread the
alchemist many times because you always
pull something different from a video
game
I'll call it duty hey Michael B Jordan
it's tradition around here hand to put a
little extra on the last wing you don't
have to if you don't want to I mean you
did it I got kinda like how can I add a
feeling that's what I'm just gonna ya
little schmear action yeah I'm
controlling a little bit you know say
yes yes I'm
man where's a good dress but oh man
mm-hmm Oh milk doesn't uh doesn't help
that's there's no sort of just shake on
situation you know you're kind of just
caught in the hot sauce suit all right
let's uh yeah you serious man yeah yeah
Oh uh-huh
Oh immediately the last dad that's
suggesting just the irony oh man mmm my
lips burn bro oh yeah you know saying
one more rep yeah all right Michael B
Jordan so I know that your view of media
is that you can't really say anything
off the top of your head or ingest for
the risk that it might be taken out of
context yeah I can't say I blame you
but that's not gonna stop us from
putting you on your heels now with pens
scorching hot chicken wings whoo whoo
you know I'm gonna hit you with some
this or that and I'm just curious how
you're gonna tiptoe your way through the
minefield on this pick one stuff courier
James Harden sorry he's got a beard he's
got a beard yep
so I'm going with who'd you rather have
a five-course dinner with Leonardo
DiCaprio or Malcolm Gladwell I had a
dinner with Malcolm Gladwell I am going
leo one's got to go rocky rocky - rock
III rocky four rocky five five five
rocky fire what was more challenging
clearing these wings on hot ones or
navigating your way through the Walsh
wilderness with Bear Grylls uh oh man
whoo-hah ones
how long homeless how was you heard that
bear we're coming for the throne man
watch the crown and Michael B Jordan
looking at you getting through the hot
ones gauntlet so impressive and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you Michael B Jordan
Emeril this camera this camera this
camera huh let the people know what you
have going on - yoo-hoo oh and I gotta
talk about some [ __ ] if you want to uh
black panther in theaters yeah I'll make
sure to come out and see it it's a
movement all walks of life you guys are
welcome you know it's for everybody
outlier society we're producing as much
things as we can film television
animation video games we are an on
script that you've got a hands and
everything and um yeah me and all the
strong women out there continue you
don't seem to be you unapologetically
your time is coming and I'm saying it's
it's a it's real and yeah I love my
family my mom that's just a brother my
family of friends rock out okay okay
okay hey what's going on hot ones fans
it's Sean Evans and you know what I'm
not going to beg for your subscription
if you're not subscribed turn off the
video it's over I want just my
subscribers come here come here if
you're subscribed to first we feast I
just want to say thank you and then I
appreciate you that I love you and I
hope that you have a great day